[Musique]
si vous n'aimez pas le football éteignez
votre télé pendant un mois enfin restait
tout de même le temps du 7-8 débat
bonsoir à tous et à toutes
c'est parti pour un mois de ballon rond
matin midi soir et la nuit aussi avec
les replays le football est partout sur
tous les continents en france évidemment
et dans les yvelines bien sûr dans le
département il ya le centre
d'entraînement du psg à saint germain en
laye et bientôt à poissy mais aussi et
surtout à clairefontaine depuis 1988
théâtre des rêves de l'équipe de france
où elle peut s'entraîner tranquillement
et efficacement avant les grandes
compétitions mais finalement les
yvelines et le football n'est ce que
cela des espaces verts et un
environnement favorable aux
entraînements mais pas forcément à la
compétition aucun club professionnel
dans l'un des départements les plus
riches de france s à un problème
pourquoi nous allons poser la question à
nos invités en plateau elles sont 3
jean-pierre meurillon président du
district des yvelines de football
abderrezak guessous président de
l'étoile sportive de trappes et serge de
gris entraîneur des u19 à guyancourt
bonsoir à tous les trois un bon swing
chose alors l'introduction était un peu
provocatrice c'est vrai mais finalement
assez assez réaliste quand on regarde
les faits le département des yvelines
n'a pas vraiment n'est pas vraiment une
terre de football en terme sportif pur
je me tourne vers le président pas de
club pro chez les hommes ni chez les
femmes
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous est ce
que est ce que c'est normal pour un
département comme les yvelines
finalement on a quand même un club pro
c'est le psg oui le psg qui sont prêts à
g qui s'entraînent m'enfin l'ensemble de
son activité
et sur le département des yvelines
puisqu'ils sont actuellement à saint
germain et qu'ils vont s'installer
ensuite un poids si par contre
effectivement en dessous on n'a pas de
club qui soit en ligue 2 ou en
championnat national on a des clubs deux
clubs qui sont en nationale 2 puis en
dessous on en a quelques-uns qui sont en
nationale 3 est ce qu'on a le fc mantois
78 on allait cette fois ci et puis en
dessous on à l'os et les mureaux et le
football-club de versailles 78 ce qui
veut dire quand on est à un département
de football mais deux de football de
niveau un peu on va dire moyens presque
professionnel mais pas totalement enfin
nationale 2010 visant à y aller
c'est déjà ça j'ai un peu un peu
compliqué pour y accéder c'est
quelquefois même aussi compliqué pour
s'y maintenir pour certains c'est arrivé
par le passé que des clubs et des
difficultés à se maintenir
non mais et puis le plaisir que dans un
département comme et comme les yvelines
avec de telles infrastructures avec pas
mal d'argent puisque on le sait mine de
rien l'argent joue beaucoup dans le
monde du football
il pourrait avoir un grand club kiki
s'entraînerait et qui jouerait dans les
yvelines
oui c'est vrai mais nous notre
préoccupation au district sais c'est pas
tellement ça nous notre préoccupation
c'est que tous les gens qui veulent tous
les sauts qui veulent jouer au football
puis jouer au football et on a on a
quarante mille licenciés
c'est à dire qu'on est sur les sept
districts francilien on est le troisième
temps qu'on ait un d un des plus gros et
c'est déjà pour nous c'est ça le plus
important ensuite valley club dillon et
c'est normal d des velléités de
d'accéder aux dans les divisions
supérieures et c'est bien c'est bien
normal et puis ils ont bien raison
d'essayer de le faire mais ensuite va
tout le monde ne peut pas monter imaginé
un jeu prend toujours cet exemple
imaginer que on est dans les
championnats douze équipes avec une très
bonne de 12 clubs avec une très belle
équipe a un très bon staff un très bon
entraîneur il y aurait quand même un
premier et un dernier
donc nous ce qui nous importe c'est
qu'on puisse jouer au football dans les
yvelines qu'on puisse il jouait de façon
intéressante et et façon très très
intéressant donc beaucoup de licenciés
dans les yvelines notamment grâce à
l'étoile sportive de trappes je crois un
peu plus de 1000 licenciés dans mille
cent cinquante mille cent cinquante
licenciés ce qui fait de vous une grosse
structure qu'elle vous vous quel regard
vous portez ou sur le football dans
l'est dans les yvelines et et peut-être
cette critique qu'il n'y a pas de grands
grands clubs même si on a bien compris
il ya des clubs quand même très sérieux
oui bien sûr je vais rejoindre le
président du district 1 effectivement
bon c'est le paradoxe pour les yvelines
on peut pas le comparer aux autres
départements 93 92 95
mais il ya quand même des résultats très
intéressants depuis maintenant
trois quatre ans on a des clubs qui
accèdent à des niveaux quand même semi
pro et ça va encore continuer donc on y
arrive tranquillement les yvelines qui
arrivent mais moi j'y crois on aura dans
les amener dans les années à venir
on aura peut-être là on a encore du
chemin encore mais pourtant on y
travaille on mettra de temps qu'il
faudra mais on y travaille les clubs qui
sont déjà en n2 n3 ils font du bon
boulot
il est des bons résultats on va y
arriver
justement on va les voir sur une
infographie tout de suite pour pouvoir
un peu le niveau des meilleurs club
yvelinois en nationale 2 vous le disiez
il ya notamment poissy et le mantois
puis nationale 3 régional de régionale 3
pour le pour les autres serge de grille
alors vous vous entraînez les jeunes à
guyancourt quel regard vous vous portait
justement sur la situation du football
dans l'est dans les yvelines est ce que
vous aussi vous êtes d'accord avec ce
message que même s'il n'y a pas de club
top top ligue 1 ou ligue 2 il ya quand
même un bon niveau dans localement très
très bon niveau un excellent niveau même
pour vous dire ça commence dès le plus
jeune âge donc pour avoir des bons
joueurs de haut niveau il faut déjà bien
les préparer donc ça commence par les
petites catégories
donc il faut d'abord s'accorder un bon
bout de temps à ces petites catégories
afin de pouvoir former des bons joueurs
qui dans les années à venir je n'en
doute pas feront d'excellents
footballeurs ils feront vraiment monter
le niveau des yvelines vous ma gêne d'un
bus 19 à 15 il évolue il évolue en
division 1 cette année donc les l'ancien
excellence et malheureusement on descend
en division 2 mais bon on voit ça sa
tâche est de remonter immédiatement et
faire partie des grosses structures u19
du département on parlait tout à l'heure
du nombre de licenciés que ce soit d'un
point de vue départementale attrape
guyancourt est ce que ce nombre de
licenciés augmente
chaque année dans le département où il
ya une forme de stabilité dans les
chiffres peut-être nous étions dans un
système où on augmenter le nombre de
licenciés chaque année puis il ya
quelques années c'était il ya deux trois
ans la caisse d'allocations familiales
après une décision que j'ai contesté
puisqu'ils ont diminué par ils ont
divisé par 4 le montant des bons loisirs
et ça a coûté ou dans les yvelines ça a
coûté
une perte de licenciés des primes aux
licenciés terre des jeunes qui avaient
aussi 7 8 ans on en a perdu 1000
et puis l'année d'après la caisse
d'allocations familiales a modifié un
petit peu ils sont passés à un système
un petit peu différent ça ils ont remis
les ans ils ont augmenté un petit peu ce
qui donnait ils ont ils sont parvenus à
la soie au système précédent
et là on a repris un certain nombre
actuellement on est en est à 40 milles
on est aux alentours de 40 milles depuis
maintenant deux ans trappe
qu'en est-il à trappes pour les chiffres
osé une petite augmentation
l'un dernière la saison précédente on
était neuf cent quatre licenciés là on
fait un bon demi centre 1534 licenciés
donc on est en augmentation
c'est assez stable par rapport aux
années précédentes on est aux alentours
de 600 licenciés
ça joue quand même l'engouement des
compétitions internationales de l'euro
en france de la coupe du monde ou alors
ça c'est ce que disent les médias en
général c'est un peu un adage qu'on a
l'habitude de sortir mais c'est pas
forcément vrai non non ça joue un petit
peu mais ça on le verra justement après
la compétition pour faire une bonne
compétition là tout dépend de l'équipe
de france si l'équipe de france fait
d'excellents de compétition les dix ans
a cru à partir du mois de septembre
et cela fait qu'il ya un peu plus de
joueurs dans le département comment
quelle est la recette aujourd'hui pour
avoir un club type type lien alors pas
forcément le psg mais un club ligue 1
ligue 2 est ce que c'est de la volonté
d'abord et puis ensuite des
investisseurs est ce que c'est d'abord
la volonté politique
quelle est la recette aujourd'hui si un
jour un club des yvelines veux veux
jouer en ligue 2 ligue 1 au national
alors c'est compliqué parce que
un club de ligue 1 c'est une entreprise
c'est une véritable entreprise avec des
dépenses importantes et aussi des
ressources qui sont importantes il ya
les droits télé on en a parlé il ya peu
de temps et ils vont augmenter tout le
monde croit que c'est tout de suite
précédent 2 en 1 fois son souvenir
il y en a une petite partie on dépasse
le milliard pour la pour la première
fois en france il ya une toute petite
partie qui va revenir vers le monde
amateur 2 5% seulement presse faire le
15 j'aimerais bien que ce soit que ce
soit un peu plus mais ceci étant dit je
pense qu'il faut pas faire là la
confusion entre le monde professionnel
et le monde amateur
nous on est dans le monde amateur on
essaie de monter les clubs essaient de
monter de division d'aller d'aller le
plus haut le plus haut possible et ils
ont bien raison parce que c'est comme ça
qu'on avance
mais un club professionnel ça
s'improvise pas c'est très compliqué à
monter et puis il ya tous ceux qui y
sont qui veulent y rester
donc pour aller prendre leur place c'est
compliqué vous avez vu pour monter deux
de national en ligue 2 il faut passer
par un système de barrage très compliqué
pour monter de ligue 2 en lien là aussi
il faut mon c'est compliquer la
politique fois ci ça compte ou pas qu'un
homme politique porte un club par
exemple pour qu'un club puisse monter
oui probablement si ce n'est que ça
dépend du niveau le club se trouve mais
entre la volonté de monter très haut et
le moment où on réussisse pas ce très
longtemps et malheureux et puis c'est
ainsi le temps qu'il faut pour monter
n'était pas sur les mandats politiques
la durée des mandats politiques attrape
plus de mille licenciés régionale 4 pour
l'équipe senior numéro enfin la première
équipe senior pourquoi par exemple vous
vous n'arrivez pas à monter un peu plus
haut malgré le nombre de licenciés très
important et l'engouement qui semble en
toile le football à trappes
bah ça j'arrive pas 3 d'expliquer mais
on n'est pas sans vous fâchez
d'entreprise dans un investisseur ou la
mairie trappe mais non moi je rassure
déjà le club de trappes
comment il fonctionne il fonctionne avec
les la commune et
les licences nous n'avons aucun
partenaire voilà c'est peut-être ça le
problème aussi pour monter peut-être que
je vous faudra y passer
pour trouver un partenaire mais tant
qu'on ne sent pas encore prêt pour les
seniors nous irons pas chercher un
partenaire pour 6 lorsqu'on sera prêt
les partenaires viendront d'eux mêmes
la porte du club à partir de là il y
aura un projet qui sera construit
ensemble ce que je veux dire c'est que
l'important pour nous c'est aussi
l'accueil l'accueil l'accueil des
adhérents
l'accueil de tout le monde a une
pratique avec une licence abordable
voilà c'est ça le plus important pour
nous pour la structuration mois une
terre de foot c'est pas seulement des
clubs pourraient tout misé sur les
autres si on veut monter on peut tout
misé sur les seniors mais c'est pas
c'est pas notre objectif
on a des très bons résultats chez les
jeunes que nous on a démonté en jeune on
a nos u19 qui ont augmenté en r2 on a
nos u17 qu'on fait un beau parcours qui
sont 2e qui joue déjà en r2 peut-être
potentiellement un code cela peut être
sur le plateau je veux pas créer de
problèmes lol on a ce qu'il faut
y'a pas de souci là-dessus on a ce qu'il
faut des éducateurs formés ya pas de
problème vos jeunes montent vous avez
l'habitude et aussi de fréquenter les
jeunes ça aussi c'est peut-être une
difficulté quand on n'a pas de d'énormes
structures c'est de pouvoir garder les
bons jeunes ceux qui évoluent dans vos
villes peut-être que le psg tout de
suite vallée ça aussi c'est un problème
important
serge de gris quand vous avez pépites ou
au moins quelqu'un qui pourrait se
révéler comme une pépite de pouvoir le
garder
ça peut la garder ça peut être un
problème mais ça peut être aussi un
avantage de faire voir le club autres
parcs dans sa propre ville
c'est effectivement c'est un avantage
dans ce cas là mais c'est un
inconvénient quand on perd nos bons
joueurs de pouvoir bien former une
équipe pour pouvoir grandir avec donc
après il ya deux poids deux mesures sur
sur ces clubs les yvelines est connu
pour être un département formateur avec
un bon niveau de formation il ya
beaucoup de joueurs qui sort d'ici
selon mes informations il ya moussa sow
récemment qui est sorti du département
des yvelines nous
nicolas anelka probablement qu'il joue à
trappes dans ses plus jeunes années
cette année on a
on a fait signer deux joueurs de jeux
deux jours on a un jeune
travis l'ajauxerre en u17 nationaux et
là on vient de finaliser cette semaine
u19 avec un contrat de deux ans aspirant
à châteauroux immunitaire de formation
tout à fait il ya vraiment un effort et
alors nous avons autour de la table de
deux clubs qui font de la formation qui
la font bien puisque il faut rappeler
que le fbi en cours est un club
labellisé labellisée par la fédération
française de football il y en a dix sept
dents sur 153 club y en a dix sept qui
sont labellisés dont le fbi en cours et
dont le strap et le strap il faut le
savez rien dans la mission et le strap
est également titulaire du label des
écoles de football féminine
il ya deux ans il avait le niveau bronze
l'année d'après ils ont le niveau argent
ils viennent d'obtenir le niveau or
c'est remarquable c'est bon marqueur
qu'est ce que ça veut dire concrètement
labellisé qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça
permet qu'est ce que ça signifie
alors c'est en fait une incitation mise
en place par la fédération pour que les
clubs se structurent et donc pour
obtenir ce label il faut remplir des
conditions en matière d'effectifs en
matière d'effectifs dans un certain
nombre de catégories d'engagement des
équipes de nombre d'éducateurs de nombre
d'éducateurs de nombreux indicateurs au
prorata du nombre de du nombre de
joueurs et aussi de la qualité des
éducateurs parce qu'il faut aussi que
les éducateurs sur des cadres formés et
diplômés
voilà et c'est tout ça avec un
encadrement qui doit être l appeler une
question sur une réflexion pour
éventuellement avoir même si c'est pas
nouvelle mais un globe avec une certaine
structure à certains niveaux est ce que
la fusion est une solution quand on voit
saint quentin en yvelines un bassin de
250000 personnes beaucoup de clubs
parfois même plusieurs clubs dans une
même ville à plaisir est ce qu'il y
aurait pas intérêts parfois rapprocher
certains clubs pour continuer à avoir
quand même une certaine proximité c'est
possible j'imagine par exemple autres
lui en cours et rap c'est pas une idée
pour vous mais est-ce que vous c'est un
cheminement qui qui a du sens selon vous
la fusion pourra construire des clubs
encore plus serein financièrement encore
plus un financièrement et plus plus
structurée encore sage de grille
ça peut ça peut être une idée mais après
voilà comme on parle souvent de
compétition pour aller au plus haut
niveau
puis après faut s'accorder entre les
villes par rapport au niveau des parents
ça va être un peu compliqué de dire
voilà votre enfant va jouer dans telle
ville aujourd'hui demain et jouera dans
tel stade dans une autre ville ça peut
être un choix un peu
difficile à accepter pour certaines
personnes est-ce que c'est aussi parfois
une guerre d'égos que chaque ville veut
garder son club pour l'image non c'est
je rejoins c'est complexe c'est complexe
de transvaser les enfants les parents
des clubs comme puis on compte en libye
ne sont pas si éloignées que ça des
clubs comme guillon cours trappe avec
une fois les frontières sont mis
l'essence de 21 ans elle entre à partir
de 500 licenciés ça devient vraiment
très très sérieux très très complexe par
contre l'idée
l'idée de nous on a une idée c'est
pourquoi pas
la communauté d'agglomération a scarlets
comme il finance le sport de haut niveau
comment elle actuellement actuellement
nous n'avons pas de finances de
subventions à nous les clubs amateurs de
l'art est pourquoi dans les mairies
roche imaginez une équipe une équipe
saint quentinois
mais une équipe senior saint quentinois
qui va peut-être tiré vers le haut vers
la compétition le plus haut possible et
non gare de rennes où nos jeunes nous
nos enfants
mais l'ex enseignant serait par exemple
lancé saint-quentin-en-yvelines
labellisé cinquantaine
qu'en est il de cette idée de fusion
pour vous c'est une solution pour avoir
un bon club quand on voit par exemple
poissy et le montois qui joue en
national de tous les deux qu'ils sont
très peu éloigné on se dit que si les
deux clubs se rapproche on pourrait
avoir un truc de nationale 2 ligue 1 qui
sait oui enfin c'est c'est pas si simple
à mettre en place un le président le
disais à l'instant c'est complexe et
c'est vrai que c'est très passionnant et
touche un peu plus la politique aussi la
rime et moi j'entends parler de cette
possibilité d'avoir une équipe un
certain niveau qui soit entre guillemets
communautaire c'est à dire la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
j'en entends parler dope il
la création de la non pas de la
communauté mais de la ville nouvelle
c'est depuis toujours qui a été mise
mais je me dis que si on n'a jamais
réussi à le faire c'est que sans doute
ça doit être beaucoup plus compliqué
qu'il n'y paraît plus bas une réflexion
encore sur sur les plus grands clubs de
football dans les yvelines c'est poissy
et mantes la jolie c'est les mureaux ces
trappes au siècle le nom de licencier
excepté versailles
finalement ce sont des villes populaires
c'est finalement je vais dire là où il
ya moins de moyens qu'on arrive à faire
les plus grosses structures les clubs
les plus les plus simples et plus
important des yvelines est-ce que c'est
pas paradoxal ça quand même
est ce que ça veut dire qu'ils n'ont pas
un peu de volonté aussi de certaines
villes de jouer le jeu alors déjà dans
votre liste il y en a il y en a d'autres
qui manquait à conflans conflentois qui
alors qu'ils jouent à haut niveau
puisque parents excédés soit their s'est
pas encore officiel mais ils vont
accéder en régionale 1 cet accord
régional
et puis vous avez château aussi un
château qui est très bien placée encore
sur des villes non mais voyez on a aussi
dans un certain nombre d'endroits dans
les yvelines on a une évolution et ce
sont des équipes qui sont en train de
monter son pied petit à petit elle monte
d'un cran ensuite d'un autre cran et c
est ce que pendant longtemps en fait
vider de ma réflexion c'était de dire
que le football
bon pour les yvelines même si ça peut
paraître un cliché c'est un sport un peu
trop populaire vaut mieux avoir de
l'équitation du tennis du golf golf dans
les yvelines et finalement le football
très impopulaire nuit un peu à l'image
de certaines villes parce que parce que
pas assez représentative du jeu pense
pas que ce soit ça je pense que d'abord
donc encore une fois on a quarante mille
licenciés
c'est quand même pas rien et puis on
s'aperçoit que on a beaucoup de jeunes
on a 60 % de nos licenciés qui sont des
jeunes entre
deux seins de 6 ans jusqu'à 19 ans on a
plus en plus de filles en l'espace de
quatre ans on a augmenté de 111% le
nombre de joueuses et j'espère que ce
qui va se passer cette année avec la la
coupe du monde des u20 qui va se passer
en bretagne l'été prochain et en 2019 la
coupe du monde tout court des féminines
qui va se passer dans toute la france
je pense que ça va faire du beaucoup de
bien au football féminin ça va encore
plus le développer justement aujourd'hui
ce que ce serait pas plus simple de
miser sur le football féminin dans les
yvelines pour avoir un club de taille
importante c'est peut-être plus simple
en terme de finances encore aujourd'hui
le football féminin se développe mais il
reste encore un cran en dessous du
football féminin en terme de technicité
de pour monter des projets qu'en
pensez-vous sk l'étoile sportive de
trappes c'est un projet le football
féminin d'avoir un grand club
oui c'est un projet tout ça fait trois
saisons déjà qu'on a la section féminine
et c'est vrai qu'elle est en nette
augmentation chaque année puis comme
vous l'a précisé le président n'a obtenu
le label or donc on se structure petit à
petit mais c'est un engouement très
important et c'est un projet qui est
phare aussi au club
sargis aussi les filles viennent de plus
en plus au club de guyancourt on a de
plus en plus de filles de tout âge de 6
à 77 ans donc voilà maintenant notre
équipe senior féminine va peut-être
avoir la possibilité de pouvoir jouer en
ligue l'année prochaine j'aurai aimé que
ça veut dire en terme de niveau ça veut
dire un niveau au dessus
la langue aux régionales r31 d'accord
donc pas de ce fait ça va attirer de
plus en plus de filles au club et ça va
pouvoir développer l'activité au sein de
la ville nouvelle aux city contre et
contrairement
au masculin les filles et est monté et
démonté sont plus rapides oui c'est pour
ça je disais l'idée peut-être d'avoir un
club très important féminin c'est
peut-être plus simple de miser sur les 1
oui peut-être mais le il faut laisser le
football féminin se développe et je veux
dire que est certes on a besoin des
équipes de très haut niveau mais il faut
aussi le laisser les c'est le foot
féminin se développer dans les clubs et
les choses vont venir naturellement avec
des efforts parce que rien ne vient sans
effort mais ça va se faire mais il faut
laisser les choses avancent et messieurs
on arrive bientôt vers la fin de cette
émission on a parlé du foot local
devrait faire un mot vu qu'on est en
pleine coupe du monde est là elle a
débuté là il y avait quelques instants
cette coupe du monde sur vos espoirs
pour pour l'équipe de france et puis sur
cette coupe du monde selon vous est ce
que l'équipe de france peut gagner la
coupe du monde c'est pour conclure ce
débat on va parler quand même de
l'équipe de france et ce qu'elle peut
gagner cette coupe du monde
et si oui où sinon du coup qui va gagner
cette coupe du monde devait commencer à
vous serge degrés je les mets dans les
favoris mais avec un grand sérieux de
tout le staff et des joueurs
je pense qu'ils peuvent aller au bout
c'est possible de gagner la coupe du
groupe
je pense qu'ils peuvent aller car à
partir de quel moment ça serait un échec
selon vous pour l'équipe de france à
quel stade vous mettez là le plancher
pour l'équipe de france
au vu du dernier euro je les vois pas
sortir avant le dernier quart et donc
les deux fidèles pour vous à l'étoile
sportive de trappes qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous ambitionnez pour
l'équipe de france
du sérieux en tout cas ce qu'on a vu là
ils sont concentrés
on sent qu'il ya un groupe bien géré et
ouais ça se passe bien pour le moment si
ça reste dans cette dynamique il ya
quelque chose à faire
jean-pierre meurillon en tant que le
président du district local
on peut servir que j'espère
effectivement que l'équipe de france ira
le plus loin possible
formant et qu'elle fasse ce qu'elle a
fait la dernière coupe du monde s'est
demandé à quel moment on considéra
qu'elle n'a pas réussi il faut au moins
qu'elle fasse ça moi j'espère qu'elle va
aller très loin
je pense qu'elle a les moyens de réussir
mais pourrait aussi est livrable
seulement être bon mais il faut aussi
avoir un petit peu de type eu de
réussite en 98 mais alors nous nous
distrait des yvelines on a fait quelque
chose pour que les choses se passent
bien
c'est que en 98 on a tenu notre
assemblée générale à l'ogcn et cette
année on a recommencé on fait notre
assemblée générale le 23 juin ce sera à
louveciennes aussi alors c'est un signe
ainsi un clin d'oeil qui c'est qui ces
lycées d'agression ce que localement
vous allez d'ailleurs faire des
événements avec avec les enfants avec
les licenciés pour la coupe du monde si
la france va peut-être un peu plus loin
c'est l'objectif de réunir tout le monde
le temps d'une soirée
ce sera prévu sergerie ouais vous c'est
peut-être par le premier match qu'il ait
déroule samedi à midi donc en plein
pendant de notre tournoi régional
or il ya un écran j'en suis sûr on va
faire en sorte que les enfants puissent
participer à cet événement qui qui leur
tient à coeur
merci à tous les trois d'avoir participé
à ce débat prochaine émission jeudi
prochain à 18h30 en direct sur tv 78
d'ici là vous retrouver cette émission
en replay sur tv 78 points comme ou
l'application tv 78 merci encore à tous
les trois merci et bonne soirée
[Musique]